citizens of the reject Nation we are
back for another DC animated film today
we're gonna be watching justice league
dark a favorite comment of my comic and
Comet I love the comment we've made
comment Justice League
just do that let us know you appreciate
it you haven't seen justice league dark
I haven't and I'm so excited I love this
comic Arc I love this storyline this is
one of the things I've wanted most
adapted Guillermo del Toro is attached
to this for quite some time so I could
see him coming back now that creators
are getting a little bit more stake in
the DCU but you do know a scout because
there's a certain character in this I
know we both enjoy oh I'm so excited I'm
excited for John Constantine I'm sure
he's gonna be just like Keanu here of
course he's not gonna be blonde or
British he's gonna be animated Keanu I'm
wondering do we get detective chimp does
that name alone give you excitement
cause it should one of my favorite
characters in the entire DC Comic
Pantheon is I hope he's a good character
I'm excited for this goodness we're
excited watch it with you please leave a
comment let us know if you want to see
detective Chimp in live action and
animation let us know what you want us
to watch next let us know what you're
enjoying of these watches like this
share this hit that subscribe Bell you
know what to do and remember patrons can
sync up with us to watch it front to
back beginning to end all synced up we
don't play the video because we are
neither of the brothers Warner but we do
watch the whole thing in its entirety so
you get our resting faces
so if you want that head over to patreon
to become a super sexy reject so without
any further Ado whatsoever let's get in
to justice league dark real quick before
we hop in though just want to say a
quick thank you to our friends at G fuel
for sponsoring this Channel and keeping
us energized throughout these reactions
they are a lifesaver and if you want to
save yourself 20 on select tubs go on
down in the description box hit our
special link use the promo code reject
nation and let's jump into justice
league dark
oh Washington not Gotham Washington DC
why did you say that name some idiot
just hit me do you realize how much this
is going to cost not in money which I
have plenty of but it
oh man it's gonna cost a lot of money
she has plenty of
oh damn
way worse than that
that's right you run those no moves down
oh she's just massacring
from home
a bunch of dead human beings oh god oh
jeez
I see only one
oh this poor woman I'm your wife
it's just like the neighbors go to my
shed you'll see I'm right
I wasn't really necessary
oh no
how many people just got killed that is
so Sinister oh this body's like wrapped
up in the back it's very Adept at
killing for just a random guy sure you
gotta have a hobby you know a little
Dexter on the side let me help you
it's not my fault
giving birth to
them Motorhead
wow
[Music]
oh I mean this is uh the different tone
caramel Del Toro was was very curious
when making this I would have loved it
yeah
they weren't kidding justice league dark
man
Hunter and Jon Stewart I don't think
we've met no there could be an
overriding Factor perhaps a paranormal
element damn oh boy are you talking
about magic
we've come up against magic before
Batman the criminally insane don't need
magic as an excuse I recommend spending
more time on the streets instead of
flying over them
still don't believe in magic
oh yeah let's get some Hollow Man action
[Music]
wow oh no
oh cool let's do this
yeah I also like the Batman nicked
himself shaving you know straight razor
shave even Batman messes up do you bleed
I do sometimes
what an intro man nah this is Hardcore I
think this one is actually rated R so I
mean it seems like it would need to be
so far
too bad on standing
have you gained weight it looks good on
you
like these Cockney demons
I raise with what I'm betting the house
the house of Mystery
whoa
oh cool
[Laughter]
a chipped dreamstone I'm out
broken knickknacks for the house of
mystery and its contents are you mad
I've got a working Soul catcher it's
still a big ass Ruby
that dreamstone must have been activated
it's a losing end for the ages Now read
them and
you chase it what
by undoing my cheating how did they
cheat my cheat rip your bloody heart out
sorry mate I'm using that
[Laughter]
oh
it's time to call you better off sorry
John you're on your own
don't look behind the bar and just keep
destroying the smartest demons
[Music]
wow
oh boy
you're a world-class bastard John a
world clustered so you like Irish in
this he's very very Cockney but there's
definitely an Irish lilts to his uh his
British in this his meaning
Constantine's in case that wasn't clear
blood's accent I mean you you get it
[Music]
sweet I will make this terrible Trio of
terrifying tanters vanish before your
eyes let's get alliteration it's the
real magic word play
[Music]
damn
[Applause]
good work good work I hope those
elephants survived
you don't want Peta on your back
the ultimate terrorist organization you
know where I can find John Constantine
we don't keep in touch
I know you two have history so I oh
[Music]
see Batman needs to talk with John you
gotta come along too it's important whoa
is that you Boston
oh dead man jump hold yeah
whoa what is going on
Boston was in the middle of his
death-defying act when
oh no
oh
nice transition
ramakrishna oh my and gave him the power
to possess the living so he could bring
his killer and others to Justice hey I
don't want to break but I'm good
it's like they're driving into The
Shining
who
can't hold it do something
yeah not in Gotham anymore even the
Batmobile can't drive in a tornado
the high-speed tornado Chase I never
knew I wanted with that man's a ton on
Batman to what do I owe the visit the
league thinks that a recent spike in
homicides may have a magical cause
you're online
it's handy
whoa hey I told you not to do that
Orchid it's the magic of the house
decided it wanted to experience humanity
and gave itself a body
cool he sure did
oh geez your life is a patchwork of
Blackness with no time for joy
how do you cope with it
have a butler
[Laughter]
yep
oh man
if we do it as a group this is the
monkey cage in Sumatra all over again
hey maybe we'll get your boy detective
champ he's a monkey he's the monkey
Obama says we have to work together you
can lead us even deities can get it
wrong it's how we got the appendix
neanderthals and reality TV
[Laughter]
he's dead and I accept the risks so come
get to it
ah
go stand in the corner he's dead and I
accept the risks where are we going
Richie's has he told you
oh no oh Dementors
why don't you go do something useful
like haunt a house who's he talking to
now
[Laughter]
they're drawn to you
and maybe it's a cologne battery this
one has
one has many times
[Music]
I wonder what Batman's cologne actually
is
Darkness Batar Noir
probably not making proper amends isn't
related to the key which truth be told
you're not gonna need mate
oh
we're saying upbeat attitude can help so
what I'll focus on today is that I met
Batman
power positive thinking I like this guy
very much
a little Cape little yeah little Batman
run into the hallway it lets me access
different planes of existence without
doing 20 odd hours of incantations in
this case I'll poke around this poor
swords memories to see how his Madness
began
it's got like a northern accent yeah
it's definitely london-ish
um
the healing can begin they're holding
hands laughs
I don't know what to make of this well
delivered yeah props to Jason O'Mara
[Music]
again
oh God
it's like Dogma it's gonna be a poo
monster hey is it the golgatha monster
oh Jesus oh God
demon turd
imagine how that smells this was the
morning of his Madness what do you think
will set him off
Sauron
Sauron yeah like a ring on
foreign
[Music]
yes
death by Electro potion
gotta smell even worse now that's all
charred oh it's like reheated
now John there's no
[Music]
grab it
drop it
oh no no no
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
he'll even tip for the janitorials now
every time you've arrived kind
s
no
come on no
the apartment was like that when I
arrived when you burst in I knew I'd get
blamed so I ran he's chock full of Honor
loyalty and rubbish of that sort
the single most powerful conduit of evil
in the history of the world
he named it the dreamstone
but it's really the stuff of nightmares
bars Destiny forged the dreamstone with
black magic and his soul he used it to
subject people to their most terrifying
nightmares and then feed off their
torment it's tasty
[Music]
oh no
ow staff kind of looks like the Shazam
wizard staff there's the wizard hey oh
oh
if freedom is what's up for trade and
Destiny is as good as slaves yes
kill him with dope rhymes
oh
this isn't over I swear it
whoo I apologize to wealth you and Jason
blood
in the form of man
I fix the demon at regard fitting that
that incantation should rhyme as well
etrick man God I want to see these
stories live so bad who was it who did
this to you
fast
Felix Faust oh Dr Faust viendas locom
Felix fast
what's happening If This Were a computer
I'd say it's frozen
I order you to help him any and every
way you're able
oof I think you can boss me around just
because I'm a house yeah you created me
kinda why are we in the middle of a god
forsaken swap it's a favorite hidey hole
of one Alec Holland yes I know you're
seeing this get out here all the Posies
get it
all right
now you've done it
[Music]
sick Faust lives in an observatory which
is invisible it's a place where dark
magic would infect the earth below it I
will take you there
so you are no longer here
get the hell out of my swamp perhaps his
actions are a kind of justice for who
destroys more of the green than your
kind I Justice
oh
he is pissed
Wanda
the dark hold
on
I don't like what I've done with the
place
no woman can speak in my sanctum
sanctorium I conjured it just for you oh
Jesus dude as classy as that Fu Manchu
real winner
God
damn
those are chaotic all this is not
everything can be solved with your pea
shooter
just because you're dead and doesn't
see this is what Doctor Strange could be
yeah
Sinister strange things just got out
I'd love to see you cook your own Goose
yeah peashooter cubestantine
[Music]
that's a Nifty feature the double shot
I take it back that thing is useful
yeah put some respect on that pea
shooter
whoa
oh cool
I know you can't speak but give me away
you're the only one here that's really a
threat oh that's nice at least he
acknowledged that
oh damn
[Music]
a great piano strikes
yes
oh God
[Music]
play it backwards
numbers
cool
anime fight scene so sweet
the biggest anime Sword this is why I
wanted a Tana movie don't kill him out
of my way John
if no blood is spilled your Soul's in
the clear
that controlsy just like I told you
oh
it's okay Z no He does care
what happens to the best of us
you've seen me in action right in
practice
this yours
I don't know maybe I have several
hundred rings of varying design and
properties
[Music]
it isn't him he signed our own poker
buddies in their more massive forms we
were sent here by your friend remember
but Richie's dying
dying is he oh no
what are you gonna do with that came I
don't trust it
oh damn
it no uh I liked you man so Charming I
think I got closer to death and I
planned
see now you were told to do everything
to help me by the by the Master of the
House and that does not include punching
help your soul
I'd need you out of my hair for now so
why don't you just go for a little walk
yes
no
nothing happened to the house if this
happens
yeah that's the stuff oh the phasing
game Hostess why aren't we in side
because Richie's bloody well taken
control of the house
this is what you get for having mates
the stone isn't sentient what's left of
Destiny's Soul was whispering sweet
nothings in your ear getting you to
commit atrocities to gain power and make
his move oof you're just pissed cause I
won I wish that were the case it'd be
much easier to deal with
um
yeah
oh damn we had a deal
yeah sure you did oh
deal with the demon
500 years I've waited
500 years I've planned yes
what say we share your beauty secrets
over the pine day a God does not prattle
with Mortals
even about my beauty my skin care is my
secret
foreign
the amount of magic she's used
sometimes you don't recover
got this figure
chilling in the back to tank over here
she's healing magically with fire all
around
chaos Reigns
this floats on by
[Music]
careful oh God they're everywhere
oh jeez the Justice League are on their
way but make sure they stay well away
from Destiny to not be struck mad unless
you want a bunch of crazy super blokes
ripping apart the city yeah all the boys
yeah a little late for that my friend
oh no
oh boy oh boy
get away
oh no evil Batman Beyond
yeah
that's why those counter measures are
important Batman
so Constantine calls once more just like
a greedy wanted save the bloody right
uh uh that's okay we all know what
you're doing we got you at your gun
[Music]
all this Poetic Justice it's Justice
oh wait a minute yeah I was gonna say
they separate damn
calling for help
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes
the defender of the green the Swamp
Thing yes
defeat him with the natural world yes
oh
[Music]
yeah
oh don't taste me bro
oh so she'll see the truth glad to see
you back on your feet
damn
[Laughter]
she can pause Superman damn man take
that magic vulnerability lightly yeah
Ah that's a home run so badass
with the fly traps the so-called
guardian of the green who secretly hopes
to be human again let me dispel you of
that notion
whoa
[Music]
no no
ah
back to the dirt
where you belong
[Applause]
[Music]
no Swamp Thing he's getting more
powerful by the second what the hell are
we gonna do a trojan horse Boston come
on
Boston's a great Airline you're wrecked
somehow he's the eyeliner
what happened to not rattling with
Mortals eh you chatter like my grandma
at a book club
now Boston
Trojan Horse
excellent
[Music]
[Laughter]
damn
sends his regards
sure
taste your own medicine
gotta save me you owe me you owe me
can't take the chance Destiny is still
pulling his strings
whoa
oh no
that was unpleasant sure oh
no
yeah that wound yeah
that happened on the day he was bound to
etch again and now that I'm not
I'm truly sorry Jason no it's a welcome
end
I mean you went out heroically for sure
hundreds of years of life being a hero
constantly gotta lose two friends today
though we were cursed to be slaves to
each other
I know of no man I'd want more for a
brother
farewell mortal
it's beautiful
Batman asked me to be in the Justice
League
nice they want you too
[Laughter]
good onesie
you've got to be bloody kidding yes
maybe I'll be in a bit Rush
could you tell me more over a drink we
could uh request in the house as it were
yeah just one drink don't think this is
gonna turn into some sort of Manchester
weekend we could have a tree riddle
Tuesday
no definitely not let's mark that as a
maybe
so cool yes
[Music]
a couple of cold ones
go to her yeah
[Music]
that was so good that was a delight oh
man
I want a Constantine it's a ton like the
dark weird mysticism of DC is so cool
yeah no like this got my mind going in
all different directions of just like
mad anticipation to see the this side of
the universe really utilized and
realized on screen because I haven't
even seen like the Keanu Constantine
movie like I I have
you know vague little catches of let's
see are there any any interesting voices
right here Rosario Dawson back says
Wonder Woman Molina was Destiny
ah okay okay
you've never seen uh keanu's Constantine
never seen it no yeah it's like I know I
know who the you know I know the
character obviously and I've seen like
little Snippets of the show and I've
seen you know uh you know bits out of
comics and stuff like that but yeah like
he's fascinating dude sure sure and and
this is a side of the world where it's
like yeah I have like a baseline sort of
familiarity but
yeah like to see the dark and the
occultish and the Magical side of DC is
still something that for me uh live
action would be a very expansive
experience yeah and this was fantastic I
think they adapted this very well
um the occult stuff translated like I
love the anime influence a lot of the
fights yeah true it's really like an
intense movie like it's a R-rated
visceral experience like this was I hope
we get a live action soon but I love
that this exists in this medium to just
like introduce people to it yeah
absolutely and then like it makes
total sense like I think it's a really
nice device that yeah you have the
Justice League Heroes who are all
susceptible to Magic and that is a big
point of vulnerability so yeah you do
need this entirely separate team that is
all magic oriented and and sort of uh
oriented toward the dark arts and the
Occult and all that stuff there's a ton
of stopping Superman in his tracks right
behind Batman that was so bad up so it
was such a cool moment yeah yeah yeah
and it's stuff like that like that was a
really rewarding moment and so like I
would love to expand just that palette
you know yeah and there's so many I mean
like we didn't even get detective chimp
didn't even get him a crime a travesty
but that's how like there's so many
really cool justice league dark
characters there's so much lore in
history and I'd much rather see R-rated
a cult than like Doctor Strange like I
think that Guillermo del Toro making
something like this would be absolutely
incredible and I think it was like eight
years he was attached to it wow it was a
long run and this was 2017 this might
have been like okay we're not getting
the Guillermo one let's do this like
it's that recent
on who else there was like Doug Lyman or
something was trying to make one for a
minute too now he's doing ballerina okay
he's doing the Constantine I mean um
John Wicks been off yeah okay so
something cool and edgy and dark it's
kind of like a Constantine spin-off by
the distributive property of Keanu yeah
exactly like that was excellent man I
really dug that I'm so glad like it's
gonna be really hard to rank these I
know right halfway through I was like
damn this is good too yeah and
especially yeah with like the different
sides of the universe and the
oscillating flavors and stuff like that
it yeah I I both
uh gleefully anticipated but also
Dreadful the fact that we've got another
Constantine movie we've got justice
league dark apocalypse War like we have
more of this so I'm I'm genuinely truly
excited because I thought yeah this was
really nicely done but it also was one
of those things where I'm like no no I
want to keep on spending time in this
world can we stay occult I just want to
get to know all these people and and
what their lives are like too and I and
I you know heavily look forward to that
just because I have to imagine that in
you know at least here in this
continuity this is you know new we're
peering into a different side of the
world so you know you don't have quite
the same amount of just you know like
spending time in the life of that we've
had with like the different main core
Justice League characters not that we've
done like you know slices of life with
them all but you know throughout these
movies thus far even you know we've
gotten to know them and especially as
we've had you know the consistent
um you know the the continuity you know
some of these films have been outside
continuity but yeah having the
consistent sort of build up of like okay
there's the Amera Batman and all these
other you know uh characters that are
you know
through existing on a through line
um yeah it's like I would love to create
that through line then for the dark
characters you know Constantine and
zatana and and whoever else like dead
man
had you had any exposure to that man
no he's a weird one not really he's a
fascinating character sure for years I
was like what's this fake Daredevil
doing and then like it's even got the
collar and everything when I met him I
was like all right he's pretty cool but
I always thought like why is this guy
almost Daredevil and then like
especially I don't know something about
like the robin element of his origin I
was always like man and then I I found
the heart of them I was like oh he's a
fascinating character he's so broken I'm
just curious like I know this storyline
uh-ish because like it's very etragon
based like a lot of these elements I was
familiar with but like I don't even know
what apocalypse would
interact with the justice league dark
like like I've never seen apocalypse
interacting with magic okay so that's
really exciting to me sure and like we
we didn't do Killing Joke so we'll
probably do that at some point but like
we have so much in the next six years to
catch up to modern day and like there's
still new ones coming out like there's
still like I just found out today Jack
Wade playing Superman on the show what
Jack wait Superman I had no I just found
out today damn so like there's stuff
getting cranked out at all times and
like I don't even know how many of these
there are but I'm so excited to keep
diving into like the the lore getting
enriched I think there was like two back
to back that I was meh about so I'm
starting to get worried but we've had
like four in a row that have been
excellent yeah yeah no no like way more
more hits than than misses and even the
misses they've just been like pretty
good fine the misses are like B minus C
pluses maybe a c but the hits are like a
like they're they're way better than the
other ones are in May yeah yeah yeah for
sure and and yeah like this certainly
did like kind of wash over me in a way
because there's a lot happening and
there is a lot that you're being
introduced to but uh it felt chaotic in
the right sort of way and I love that
you start out in just the shoes of norm
normal people as these hallucinations
are yeah you know descending upon
everybody and it's like it's a really
unsettling intro it almost it's reminded
me of like the better version of some
kind of M Night Shyamalan scenario where
yeah it's just you have these people who
can't help but you know fight what their
eyes and ears are telling them and then
yeah realizing that some kind of
horrible sort of blanket magic has
descended upon everybody
um this is like a really great hook and
then the way that that takes you then to
you know slowly meeting each of these
figures one by one Constantine zatan
what's the uh the house the the
personification of the house what's her
name oh what was her name it's like
Firefly or something it's not that but
no but it was something like in that
vein but yeah I also love that the
opening allows for us to feel the
Justice League be powerless like what is
Superman gonna do against people like
being taken over yeah like what's what's
cynical Batman gonna do and I love
Batman just like like there were so many
like Haram moments for Batman and like
we get to see a new side of him in a
world that he doesn't have control like
he he can't really fight magic but then
also you see the technical side of him
like he knows how to take on the Justice
League themselves like you accomplish a
lot in this story yeah and he's the
right figure as much as like you know
you just always want to hang out with
Batman because Batman is super cool
Batman he seems like the right figure to
Traverse both teams yeah the darkness of
him kind of fits somehow yeah and the
non-magic or the non you know
Supernatural quality that that basically
yeah he's just a guy with his intellect
and his wits and his Tech and so that I
think makes a nice also physical means
for him to exist between both if it was
Superman trying to do both it was like
man you're a huge vulnerability to this
team whereas Batman yeah he can if he's
taking over you're like well we can
still take him out he's like he's a guy
yeah and it's like I also kind of
appreciate that I mean not to to
yeah not to praise like the lack of an
ark and not to say that there isn't an
arc but I like that it's not the sort of
like and then John Constantine learns
how to oh yeah no he's always like dude
Constantine is a constant it's great
because there's moments of humanity but
overall like he's prick sure and I love
that about the character like his
Redemption Arc is like he's less of a
dick today yes yeah that's so fun and I
I mean I really do look forward to
hopefully we get detective chimp but
also like Swamp Thing was so well used
there Swamp Thing was fascinating and
intense and like now that I I can't stop
thinking about D'Onofrio as him and like
that's such a powerful choice and if we
get James Mangold making basically like
a movie about an existential Planet
crisis character like there's so much to
be done there sure and I mean that's
that's the thing about a movie like this
and it's not a gripe it's just one of
those where I'm like ah man every
location every place we go every new
character we meet I just want to like
spend some time just unpacking this and
I did appreciate that at least that
first encounter with Swamp Thing is
just a a confrontation of sorts it's
just you know an intellectual sort of
thing where they're yeah they're trying
to convince him to help and he's clearly
got his reasons to stay you know
separate and and the mood of that and
just you know being in the swamp and
beholding his presence and even just the
way that they realized him the way that
he speaks and the sadness like when the
corpse gets pulled out of him like you
felt so much that connection and like we
just met we in one movie we met him and
then felt all that for him like that's
impressive they did so much in an hour
and 20 minutes they did oh they did they
they really did my question then is is
he gonna come back I assume they'll be
able to they'll put him back together
yeah I hope so yeah I hope there's a
Swamp Thing movie like swamp thing's one
of those characters you can do so much
with the Lynn ween run is genius uh the
the more modern stuff with Neil Gaiman
is incredible
um I mean it's only like 10 years later
but like he's only like invented in the
80s he's a newish character like
compared to you know the 60s and
Superman and stuff but like it's so
dense what the stories you can tell
because it's almost like poetry when you
read Swamp Thing and I highly recommend
everyone reads one thing there's also
some recent Simon Spurrier runs of
Constantine I'd highly recommend
um hellblazer with a subtitle I forget
the subtitle but Simon Spurrier the
writer and the dialogue is so rich that
you can almost like smell the feces like
the Poo monster like there's just so
much grossness oh wild like weird the
the Cockroach of in this movie but
like some of the comics recently have
captured that feeling in a really cool
way and Simon Spurrier is like a really
good hellblazer writer
um he actually went over to boom and
he's writing his own mysticism
um Cannon where he's like it's called
damn them all and it's a book about like
Witchcraft and demons that are um
basically like attached to these coins
uh much like the occult here but uh all
these coins get out into regular like
drug dealers and crime Lords and they
just have these demons now but it makes
all the like this big demonic War
basically it's like guy Richie meets
this and it's fascinating and so he's
writing that over a boom and it's dope
but it's very much like okay he's not
writing Constantine he runs to write his
own Constantine
um so there's lots of really cool stuff
in this world in this flavor if you dig
it uh and I I really think Zatanna is
gonna be the next big thing I think that
honestly
um the reason everyone was like bummed
about the Snyder world ending I get but
the opportunity for things like this and
for the weird stuff that I think is
going to be better than anything we
could have gotten tying into the Justice
League is way bigger to me like than
than getting more of that world yeah
well and I think it it allows for the
contrast of something like this because
the Snyder world is already very dark
and kind of gritty and it doesn't have
the occult necessarily doesn't have like
the magical element but it still feels
very rot and very dark and burdened and
stuff and I feel like this tone this
aesthetic Works nicely when it has an
element of contrast when you do feel
like you're descending into a place much
darker than we normally spend time in
even though I mean obviously all the
villains and various situations that
we've encountered through these movies
the comics Etc are dark and are intense
and perilous it's still there their men
shouldn't feel like that it'll be good
to have Superman be a beacon and then
this be dark yeah yeah yeah and then
realize that yes certain things you know
can only be confronted in that level of
darkness and there are certain people
who are suited to that and even they
struggle with descending to that
occasion like I appreciated the debate
with satana and that's a character yeah
where she is uh is you know she's
clinging to this life of you know glamor
and show this because she doesn't want
to lose herself in the anguish and and
run the risk of going too far down this
rabbit hole then there's so many
subplots and arcs like everyone in this
gets like her argue I think is beautiful
Constantine he doesn't have a lack of
Arc but that's who he is and that's
really interesting to see and like the
remorse he feels but also that's who he
is and he has to stay attached to the
darkness to do his job like I want all
of that action like I'm I'm elated we we
potentially will be getting that in fact
that James Mangold could literally pick
any project he wants like he just did
Ford Ferrari got so much love jumped
over to Indiana Jones like a goalie's
head since childhood if his next thing
is Swamp Thing that shows how strong the
script is or like the the pitch is that
shows how much Freedom he has because
he's not gonna go from working with
Disney making Indie to like getting
Shackled to Something in DC unless it's
like Freedom like the idea that mangled
might make something in this world is
already like oh DC knows what they're
doing sure yeah like that to me is a
cell yeah and that sounds like the the
perfect opportunity for him to stretch
into something a bit more Fantastical
but also you're like that's that's the
exact right guy for the job yeah to do
something that's going to be a little
thoughtful and brooding and reflective
but also you know sci-fi and and Logan
in D5 and Swamp Thing into your belt
like God damn mangle not to mention Ford
Ferrari not to mention like yeah no he's
like his his film mug is stacked even
before even before he became an name you
would recognize he has been holding it
down with interesting choices
interesting shifts in tone and genre and
always a steady hand behind the camera
so like I would I really hope that comes
true because yeah Swamp Thing is a
character that I've I've been very
excited to see come to life in various
ways especially live action yeah so very
much anticipating that and and yeah like
a zitana like I'm excited to see her
finally in live action too which I I
believe they've done in like TV media
yeah at least I want film but yeah yeah
yeah like just the potential for magic
across the board and Anna De armas sure
Santana I want annadarma zatana Zatanna
de armas oh I want it so bad I want an
alfredo Swamp Thing I want maybe guy
Richie to direct a Constantine movie if
he's got a good occult angle to play
with in that like language using the fun
of the language you can see some of that
Sherlock Holmes yeah like some of that
movie suggests the gentleman yeah and
then you know just sprinkle a bit more
Satan on top yeah and then you got
yourself a pie you got a stew going yeah
uh yeah so well that's gonna do it for
this one this was so good I it's gonna
be hard to rank these this was excellent
really loved this one ah Gothic man more
Gothic more demons more all that stuff I
don't know what's next that's exciting
yeah so comments we don't know what's
next but we're gonna watch it in order
we might do the killing joke we might do
whatever's next chronologically we might
who knows what's gonna happen but leave
a comment below let us know what of this
one you liked do you want to see more
etragon do you want to see detective
chimp yes you do yes you do what do we
have next please leave a comment below
share this with your friends if you want
us to keep doing these we just gotta
have people watch them so we know that's
why we're doing them so share them hit
that notification Bell and we will see
you at the next one thank you thank you
thanks for being here reject Nation
we'll see you soon this was dope
but before we leave let's get to our
patron of today's shout out and that is
the one the only a man of Legend a man
whose name much like John Constantine
and etfragon when it's yelled out it
reverberates through the halls with
power and mysticism that is of course
the only Garth McMurray that's right not
only is it a great name not only does it
have a little Irish in it not only does
both Garth and McMurray have resonance
but the man himself is great which helps
my vision's getting blurry because I
only have eyes for Garth McMurray
I like your I like your little I'm gonna
go with the the first name and say that
you know whether here or far there is no
one quite like Garth ah we did it is
there a word that rhymes more closely
with Garth it's actually harder I was
like Darth isn't real hard I was oh
Hearth oh that's great yeah when
thinking of the mystical and the lands
and homes of Constantine there is
nothing quite like the Hearth that you
get when you know Garth ooh because it's
a place and it's also a feeling and it
ties into the mysticism I like that
that's true that's just that's the old
saying I see that stitched in lots of
tapestries Garden Barry you're a
gentleman you're a scholar you're a
delight you're a sexy reject and we
appreciate you very much